sweet
suppose California wrong tell us
onwards and upwards right so la here we
come you like any ad you were going lock
the door I'm looking for 123 and a half
I'm Judy wood that looks like you found
it I need some help to do with that what
do you know about immigration law no
wait don't answer that I don't have time
to be your mentor but real cases are
always the best teacher
I'm Judy wood Judy wood Judy I have some
friends
[Music]
mrs. wari I'm Judy would your new
attorney the law of asylum only protects
you if you were part of a persecuted
group we can prove that then we have a
very good case but you must tell your
story I was arrested because I wanted
everyone to know that girls to think for
themselves the law of asylum does not
recognize women as a protected class her
male relatives become duty-bound to
protect their family honor I'll kill her
as a woman I applaud you
as a judge I must rule against you we
have a compelling basis for appeal we
just need a rock-solid brief for the
Ninth Circuit we need to look at every
case every legislative commentary come
on it dad wants me to live with him he's
never had all your love because you save
it for your clients I was throwing Janek
honest and I was throwing Jane here but
in America I can't find back their
nation of immigrants like my father it's
a beautiful day we don't get many of
these around here we have one last
chance
[Music]
that's a clear conscience nothing can
pay for the prospect that I see
day by day
you know even if you win you lose
everybody is gonna want a miracle from
you
you can't save them all I can try
give me something silver me
[Music]
you